Cara right yes hey Lucy Lane yes you you
are um you must really like here well I
left my phone here yesterday I've been a
little frazzled you uh you do not seem
like the kind of person who gets
frazzled just because I look a certain
way on the outside everyone assumes it
matches the way I feel and manfully yeah
I get that
nice Jimmy would right um well my my
milkshakes are getting milkier I should
probably get going hey Karen can I ask
you a question it's awkward and I kind
of don't want to hear the answer but
it's Jimmy seeing anyone what no no he
just moved here
what about Supergirl Supergirl I saw the
news Jimmy by her side fighting reactron
I'm so worried he's gonna find her
there's this whole no really Jimmy
thinks my work came between us but he's
wrong maybe I should have appreciated
him more but the reason I prioritize
work is because he prioritized him
Superman no matter where we were what we
were doing Jimmy took off the moment
Superman called and I couldn't complain
because of course they're off saving
people's lives he says I left him but he
loved us first Lucy I'm so sorry
and this hero wears a skirt how am I
ever gonna compete with her
you
you